please be seated this was the first of
three days the impeachment managers have
to present their case that President
Trump tried to pressure Ukraine to get
dirt on Joe Biden and withheld US
security aid as leverage nevertheless
the documents and testimony that we were
able to collect paints an overwhelming
and damning picture of the president's
efforts to use the powers of his office
to corruptly solicit foreign help in his
re-election campaign
if this conduct is not impeachable then
nothing is I would rather go the long
way from Switzerland President Trump
again called his impeachment a partisan
witch hunt he said he could live with
having new witnesses testify in the
trial it's not up to the President or
whether that said it in its trial once
it listened to a particular witness we
had that constitutional responsibility
as the courts have yielded to us in
order to carry out that responsibility
Republican senators has stuck by Trump
they include some of his fiercest
defenders they're on a crusade to
destroy this man and they don't care
what they destroy in the process of
trying to destroy Donald Trump I do care
so to my Democratic colleagues you can
say what you want about me but I'm
covering up nothing I'm exposing your
hatred of this president to the point
that you would destroy the institution
it would take 20 Republican senators to
cross the aisle to vote to convict and
remove President Trump from office the
possibility is remote the much likelier
scenario is an acquittal with the
American voter serving as Trump's final
jurors in November at the polls
Heidi Joe Castro al Jazeera Washington